[Music]
foreign
Bible studies
they were Legit to Quit
but the Ali's were the first people I
ever met ever
besides my godfather that ever spoke to
me about sex
and then I had this Puerto Rican dude on
my block Puerto Rican Nelson he lived in
the back he was a bartender in the city
he used to always ask me and he wasn't a
freak or nothing I always thought to
have one point he would molest me yeah
and even till today I think deep
sometimes in [__] Puerto Rican molest
me because he used to always have a
robot and slippers and [__]
oh my God Puerto Rican doesn't
I love that you're not sure if he did
you feel like it's maybe yeah like I
think that he ever dope me like he
didn't pull the cosm behind me because
everything about him fits like an ammo
he was just a good dude yeah that we
used to go outside and help us fix our
bike and he was a Spanish dude he was
just you know he had the sideburns and
the leather jacket and it was the
[__] their early 70s and I moved to
Jersey and he would talk to a bunch of
us and one day he would take us in the
back his claim to fame with me was that
I became friends and I go over there and
he had a black friend uh that went over
to the Rock of Gibraltar and he brought
pictures back and then he would just
talk to me and then one day he asked me
foreign
[Applause]
but one day you catch him and they're
[__] Hammond yeah and we go over
there and it's like early in the morning
like I used to go over there every
morning at 10 and wake him up and and
what's up man what are we gonna do today
give me an hour I'll go out there and
play stickball with you and he come out
with coffee and he reeked of alcohol
yeah you know he was one of those dudes
in the summer you know no air
conditioning just a dynamite dude yeah
and one day I knocked on the door and he
answers with a towel around him and he's
sitting down like he's all [__] up I
don't know Nelson he's gonna play
football he's like man not today you
know and all this [__] he goes come back
in like two hours so you know we in
those days you're punctual yeah like we
were there in two hours
he asked you guys again the [__]
curtains were still up he invites Us in
he's got a towel on
you know he turns the light on and
there's like a table filled with alcohol
you know and like oh yeah how old are
you at this point 12.
12 and I can't remember who the [__] I
walked in there with like it was like
six of us in the neighborhood that liked
Nelson but two of us actually interacted
a little closer with Nelson yeah I was
Spanish so I understood Nelson's world I
knew Puerto Rican people but I can't
believe who was the other guy that
mingled with Nelson so we had woken
Nelson up he goes come on come in we sit
on this couch you guys want a soda he
gets his ass he puts the TV on you can
see he's still [__] up from the night
before he's got the towel on and he's
like so you guys get laid and we don't
know what the [__] he's talking about
like nobody ever spoke to me like that I
had uncles that would ask me how anybody
suck your dick yet yeah are you pissing
sweet yet that type of [__] but this
oh yeah yeah when you Spanish them
you know what I'm saying yeah it's a
great line
but Nelson was basically the first
person ever but like I've known about
sex but Nelson was the first person ever
that said it could be yours you know
it's like like what do you mean you
never had sex
I got a girl right now she'll come over
and clean your bike because I'm like and
we're both like [__] [__] not bad
yeah you come up with like ten dollars
it's not like nah nah nah so that was he
never talked about it again
and then when they were sitting there
like a month
and he's drunk because he's outrageous
they haven't had sex in 14 or 12.
so he was cool as [__] [__]
so one day I go away with this kid and
he starts telling us what's his name
again Puerto Rican now so we go
is it be capitalized no the Puerto Rican
dance was cool as [__] because he used
to bring us weed from the city and he
would actually give us seven joints for
five Atlas wow he really took care of us
it wasn't like he was a bad guy which to
me meant the world because a lot of
people could bring your weed over in
those days but they say I take a joint
off the top he was like I gotta go over
anyway
don't worry about it the guy gives me a
better deal
so I always liked them because of that
so one day we're there and the church
and the girls there a girl comes out of
his bedroom me and my buddy like wow
look at Puerto Rican now someone abroad
she sits on his lap and [__] and he's
like yeah this is my girl and he's
feeling her up he's making out in front
of her I had a feeling
and me and my buddy are frozen like
we're just I can feel I can feel I can't
remember
who the [__] it was
so how old was this guy this guy had to
be 28 and the bro was like 21. but he
was he was one of those he had to be 26
maybe he was from somewhere else and he
lived there this is before the computer
before neighborhood watching before and
I know it's freaked up by a pack of 12
year olds hanging out with them no
because in those days a lot of parents
came out and played with kids I know
that's different now see it's different
never be able to play with a random
people so everybody knew him for the
neighborhood and in those days we wanted
to go into the murky Waters yeah and he
was kind of opening the door not really
to be honest to you it took a long time
it's not like he lurked this into his
house and said you guys want to have sex
this is after we knew him for a year
right we go back there all the time and
get one after a basketball game we know
him you know but now he knew we were
growing up and he knew what our needs
were I look at it now like he was he was
just trying to but we couldn't handle it
yeah so when they were sitting back that
we had a basketball game and he's like
hey man what'd you think of that [__]
broad the other day me and my brother
like oh she was banging he goes I'll
tell you what he goes tell these guys
how hot she was and me and my buddy's
like yeah she was hot he's like oh when
can we see it he goes listen
tonight in the living room
and I'll leave the window open you guys
can come by and listen
what's up you bad [__] welcome
to the Wednesday night edition of the
church Greg Fitzsimmons my main man and
[__] co-host Lee syack hello what's
up dog
nothing you and I both had a rough day
yesterday
listen my day was so [__] rough
yesterday because I didn't even know it
I went home that night I first thought
when the podcast ended I was so [__]
up I was just talking to Steve Simone
and I was not not right here I'm like I
can't make it home I went home my wife
was talking [__] about something daycare
I just looked at him I said I'm going to
bed she's like what you just walked in
I'm going right to bed I went right to
bed I got anxiety I was just telling you
guys I got anxiety in my [__] sleep
like I got up and just sat there pulled
to sleep apnea mask off I didn't know
what to do finally after the third time
my wife got up and we talked she's like
what's the matter breathe through it
next day I woke up I was still [__]
dragging ass and when I got to the
acupuncturist she said something to me
she goes you're not yourself today
what's going on I don't know she started
sticking needles in me and [__] and then
she goes what did you take last night
it's still in your system
and I go well get this [__] out
and she [__] went down to my calf and
she picked the tennis spot and shoved
that little needle in there
and I put my head down she cut me there
was smokes in the cups and [__] I was
like [__] Eddie Munster I had smoke
still coming out of me the next day
and uh I felt great after I just drank a
bunch of water the rest of the day and I
felt great last night I went to The
Comedy Store but I will never eat those
[__] [__] that [__] well you told me
you told me that we weren't gonna do it
tonight and I got here like well we're
not going deep now we switched cheap
with you we're gonna look like a daycare
center we didn't do dick gregford
Simmons
wait you this all happened last night
Monday night Monday we got [__] up
they made some special Halloween uh
Edibles for us and me and him inhale
them it was an edible that had the
devil's face Devil's face oh it was the
shop you go to yeah yeah yeah it's a
good special Halloween stuff oh we got
[__] plastic I went home I was
telling you I had anxiety in my sleep
which I never really had before like I
had to get up and think about what was
going on tough at night because you
can't go out in the street you can't
just go out to a coffee shop you can't
go see a movie you're [__] trapped in
the darkness and no life forms are
around you they're all slumbering it's
just you thank God you got a wife well
she always wakes up when I get up I mean
you know as soon as I get up she won't
get Subway what's the problem you know
and then you're up for the day no some
nights I get up for the night but it's
lat that night particularly I was so
high I would go back to sleep yeah like
I would get up get my composure and then
put the sleep apnea mask on and go right
back to sleep yeah the half hour later
get up again get my composure so what
you really need is a sleep apnea mask
that's also a bong so that you can feed
it something like that this [__]
people want to stay level yeah it was
just the was it like weed anxiety
because I got anxiety driving I saw a
cop and I was sure he's gonna pull me
over so I'll pull the U-turn and I went
all the way home like I was gonna stop
at a restaurant I was like I can't do it
no I don't get that type of anxiety no
more I was getting anxiety uh about two
years ago I would take Edibles and go to
kickboxing class and once I would run
out of oxygen oh my god
um I would become I would become so
sensitive like I would hear people going
huh and all this [__] but I would hear
it like in an echo and oh it was [__] I
would have to step outside the gym and
just listen to quiet and have to go back
in I think that's a lot of things I
respect about you but I think one of the
main things is how you're able to push
these side effects to the side and
continue being the rampant deviant that
you are you have to
you [__] that the only drug I
couldn't push to the side was blow like
once I did blow I was done for the night
there was no I'll see you in two hours
like it just affected me like I would
disappear from Rogan yeah like he's a
great guy
and Joe really cared for me like the the
the fact that he's still my friend after
all these years because at the end of
the day Joe don't really like alcohol on
drugs yeah you gotta watch it around him
with him I told people a thousand times
watch it because Joe was cool but the
next day I've got a call how you drink
19 beers and you have a problem he'll
count your [__] beers because he's
you know it's just he he does he's not
from that world so he didn't even get
high enough I mean he was probably in
his late 20s before he started yeah he's
not from that world he doesn't know much
he'll drink a Heineken or two yeah one
night he got really drunk in Vegas they
sent him a bunch of shots and that's the
night I saw that you know he's a
sweetheart of a guy that happened later
on in life when he started getting high
right so but you have to you know he
watches you because he cares about you
in a way like he'll meet and God he's a
nice guy but [__] that guy could tip him
back or whatever but he to test drugs he
did test cocaine yeah and I would do a
show with him I would open for him and I
don't already have it in my pocket I'd
have it in the top pocket or it was
already in the hotel room yeah so when I
got off that stage there was no good
nights there was no C in 15 minutes you
had an agenda it was over the phone got
shut off I locked the [__] door and
nobody was coming in I already had beers
upstairs two beers maybe and I already
had weed and I had everything I needed
for the night in this hotel room you
could stay in there alone and do blood
all [__] night who the [__] sits
alone and does blow I've never heard of
that in my life you know it's it's the
type of drug that it gets when you start
it when you first do blow yeah Lee come
over
Craig's going on with Greg's coming home
we're going to get high and you know if
I can go to a bar and pick up chicks and
[__] the people you get chatty but then
the drug through time becomes something
else now
when the package is gone the package is
gone when I first started doing coke
once the last line was gone it's gone
let's go do something else then it
started we got to call the guy
let's call this [__] and get
another one
and then you start getting Coke and
leaving some at the house for later on
when you come back
you know I'll just have a beer and do a
couple lines by myself yeah and then it
gets to the point where it just flipped
on me I couldn't be around people no
more like after 12 or 13 years of doing
coke the script flipped on me
and I was always more comfortable being
by my I think since 90
94 when I got out of prison the halfway
house and all that stuff and I started
doing I was doing it always by myself a
chick would not come in that door unless
I already shook her down
what Joe what do you mean by that what I
mean by that is this girl I'm bringing
into my [__] cubicle of death
is not coming in on a maybe yeah she's
either gonna suck my dick if she's going
home right right there was no she's got
a role to play yeah I'm not going to
assign duties once we get inside there
was no plan once I get in first thing
I'm gonna do is set online and make you
take your panties off and suck my dick
yeah so I know what time it is there's
no [__] around you think I'm done you
think I'm [__] crazy you think I'm
crazy first thing I do when a girl comes
over in those days is I'd say she'd pee
Oh my God it's great to be here put the
heater on yeah and I'd go hold on I'm
cutting the line let's see what you got
under that [__] skirt and I either
eat that monkey just to get out of the
way why are we gonna sit here for three
hours with this monkey in the way
because the whole time you're thinking
about how I'm gonna [__] up what
positions look at her thighs let's get
that [__] out of the way how often would
it work every [__] time really no no
because before listen to me before she
came through the door she was already
qualified like she was already asked
shaken down like if you understand I'm
gonna do more blowout I'll come back
with you
let me tell you something I don't [__]
around you're a Savage right yeah what
do you mean what I mean is we're gonna
do a couple lines on putting you to work
and they would look at me and go you're
[__] crazy or yeah I know what do you
mean by what I'm giving you drugs I'm
turning you out and then I would say it
right out right some dick I'm gonna eat
your [__] and they will just look at
me because we're not gonna [__] around
We're not gonna make out I don't make
out what am I 10 I don't make that with
no but I want to eat that ass I want my
dick sucked I want you to play with your
[__] I want to do all creepy [__] you
know what I'm saying play with your
[__] let me watch it while I whack off
and put a Coke rocking ass this is
nothing about love there's nothing flip
over you know this is [__] nothing
this was [__] great and it worked all
the time and then you cuddle eat her
[__] no out in the morning once the
blow is done but you have no idea
because then but what I don't understand
is the alone thing like what do you do
like if I finish a gig on a Friday night
and then I go back to the hotel room and
I I have a couple puffs watch Netflix
maybe I beat off I'm asleep by 3am what
do you do when you're doing coke alone
in a hotel room what activities
transpire it is a horrible
in hindsight thinking about it now is
one of them
worst things I would do you know if you
see my face I have pics on my face I
would just sit there with the blow and
look for [__] yeah pick veins in there
really because I hated myself or I hated
the situation I was in ah so I would go
home at night all right let's say I had
a grandma called gram and a half
because I was I would go for Bro [__] a
half gram I do yeah I'd open up with a
half gram a gram
okay after a comedy show on the road
sure
the first show I had a comedy club I'm
trying to pick up a waitress or somebody
at the show
like because then looking at me going oh
yeah because right on stage I'm gonna
talk about doing blow so when I get off
stage during the first show somebody's
gonna say something to me or something's
gonna go somewhere
it's gonna go somewhere oh you do blood
or something or the second show the
second show for sure
well there's going to be people at the
bar and some girls want to come over and
go I have a blast the next thing are you
doing the blasting they got a mini skirt
and you're talking to them and this
chick's a [__] Savage you know she
didn't go out with a minisk on a Friday
night yeah because she's going to church
on Sunday she's not hanging out with the
guy with the sniffles
with the shirt going down honestly once
they start drinking it's one o'clock you
know what time and then they'll say to
you what are you gonna do after then I'm
gonna go back to the hotel room
you want to come to my plate you're
right there right there you're like
listen I got this gun he'll bring an
eight ball up Melissa I understand one
thing if I come back to your house I'm
putting a Coke Rock in the [__] and I
mean yeah and they'll look at you like
okay or oh my God you just got me hot or
no I have a husband or I have a
boyfriend I mean it's crazy but here's
the other side of the question here's
the other side that happened that I
never felt good about
there was a lot of people I brought home
that were in relationships that were in
marriages yeah you know that there was
just as much of a junkie as you were
right
you know when you have a junkie you over
uh you tolerate [__] you know I know 20
situations where I brought people home I
didn't know
[Music]
you know who I saw a picture of is uh
what's her name [__]
Jennifer Aniston no Whoopi Goldberg
Sarah Silverman at the premiere for a
movie do you see that picture I didn't
know she was so hot I don't know she
dresses up when she dresses up it's like
a whole different person I had never
seen them before it's unbelievable Sarah
Salman's a good looking little [__]
beautiful yeah she always dresses down
and I've never seen them have you seen
it yeah what I'm making that no no the
pictures what [__] picture put that
down a little bit what picture the at
her premiere who's Premiere Sarah
Silverman she's got a new movie out oh
Sarah does yeah a little indie film okay
I didn't know them yeah he's talking
about Hunger Games people are talking
about Oscar nominations and [__] yeah
really good she did a really good job
you know she's one of those people
that's been around forever she's like a
she's like age she won't go away she
can't stop it you know she's been around
with you know when I came to this town
she had just popped in Something About
Mary
even though she was just sitting at a
whole table listening she was involved
in that movie that was a great [__]
movie right my ass off
but she won't go away she's always stays
relevant you know she always pops she
popped a great HBO special last year
yeah it wasn't as much as great as how
she did it Largo yeah and all that type
of stuff so she does it her own way
she's like Joey Diaz well how else are
you gonna do it I got nobody you know I
got nobody's way to do it this is the
only way he could do it yeah what's up
Irish good to see you man [__]
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving I've been
holding that all week I've been thinking
about [__] pumpkin pies since like
last Saturday yeah like my last Thursday
like man I can't hold that no more I
need a [__] piece of pumpkin pie I'm
smoking this High cap I never got into
the pumpkin that's my favorite thing in
the world a little bit of whipped cream
on top heat that [__] up
uh and you know what I hated pumpkin pie
as a kid yeah I liked like [__] colors
like boysenberry and apple but when I
went to Catholic school I got stuck with
a pumpkin pie once oh my God how [__]
good are those yeah and the cheaper the
better right give me that little oven
once you cut up oh my you [__] Godly
with some Cool Whip Cool Whip not even
real whipped cream no no not cool with
the real [__] they can okay real whip
cool with that tub of [__] I'll go buy
I'll go to a bode and buy one of those
little entrance pies the one the size of
your fist you pop it right out of there
I've always wondered what those are the
little pie fillings they're little pie
fillings it's just like a little mini
pies 7-Eleven it's exactly a pie but
it's the size of your fist and if you're
between meals and it'll pick me up you
grab yourself an Edmonds pie apple
they'll throw it in the microwave for
you really pop it out of the tin thing
throw it in the microwave I never ate
one of those yeah it's great I don't
know what the [__] that is it's scary
like antonyms you never heard of that
Entenmann's I know but they have a
little apple pie yeah a little every pie
it's on the counter like next to this is
how fat I was I know what you're talking
about and it's next to like those little
Donuts but it says like pie filling I
was always too scared to get it I don't
know what the [__] that is I didn't know
if you had to bake it or something I've
always been a Hostess apple pie type
really that was part of my game growing
up that's a quick filler that's just
nothing but beautiful glazed yeah it's
glazed with a [__] can of Coke oh
yeah um
the dentist is like that's my boys
you know now you eat that Hostess and
it's [__] horrendous that food is all
horrendous they've taken chemicals out
they've added chemicals in remember the
Hostess cupcake just a plain chocolate
with the little [__] thing yeah the
little swirl the little swirl they gave
you like a little heavy Little Dot of
[__] sperm in there yeah now they
give you nothing it's like some [__]
little [__] with the head shoots a little
gun in there with a little [__]
little You Gotta Eat 10 pounds of
chocolate to get them a little [__]
hippie sperm it's one drop yes you get
the whole [__] load of sperm in there
from the guy at the factory now nothing
some skinny guy coughing the weeds like
white they used to be like a guy a
diabetic blew a hot thick one inside of
a cupcake those things were you know
when you from the East Coast you grow up
on those things and everybody's
different I think like South Jersey has
tasty cakes in Philadelphia up by me I
was more of uh
what did I like I like the ring dings
rest the country called them ding dongs
I'm a devil dog type of [__] but
my all-time favorite was the yo-yos the
chocolate with the cream filled up like
that and you got two in the package and
then they got dipped in chocolate the
boot that's diabetics right there yeah
another one the dentist is right there
tap on you on the
background give me a Twinkie you take
the cellophane off the little top gets
stuck on it you get to scrape that off
with your teeth they tried to stop
making Twinkies and people lost their
[__] they pick at it they protest they
wrote letters they brought it back I got
hooked on Twinkies one night Twinkies
was the first sugar Buzz I had because
my mom I would go to my mom and go mom
I'm going on a school trip and instead
of just buying me two Twinkies she'd buy
me a box and say share them with your
friends
[__] you
[__] you you would hoard the snacks
listen I would start eating those
Twinkies at 11 o'clock at night the
night before before the outcome I
remember the first all-nighter I pulled
on Twinkies one all-nighter on point
yeah and instead of snorting like when
you do blow you do like Blurry 20
minutes when you pull a long Miley yeah
[__] guys this is the funniest [__]
story of all time I pulled an
all-nighter on Twinkies one night before
we went to Philadelphia and with Betsy
Ross did the [__] letter yeah a
letter where she made the flag yeah and
we went to see The Nutcracker Suite my
mother bought a box of those a box of
something else and a box of something
else
and it wasn't the first addictive
personality that I ever showed I did not
know it then I thought about it years
later
how I kept watching him you know I
started with the out couple ah the
honeymoon was let me eat another Twinkie
then ah the octopus The Twilight Zone I
gotta have a Twinkie for the Twilight
Zone and this time I'm gonna get two and
some milk to dilute them it's in one
hour yeah we gotta get two and then at
one I watched something else I had HBO
when I was a kid so I watched something
else yeah you know HBO was brand new oh
and HBO late at night
in the late movie when I was a young man
seven when that happened not not when I
was seven
when I that happened I was in the eighth
grade so I'm talking about 78 the hot
movie at the time they kept playing that
you'd whack off to was
Kentucky Fried Movie or the Groove Tube
the group I had a chick that ran across
naked with her titties and you had that
big box with three levels
and that's how you got channels in those
days so each one had one to seven seven
to 21 and 21 that's right that was it
that was it guys that was cable [__]
TV yeah and it had a string connected to
the TV so you had let's say that that's
a TV you had a string with a box on it
and then it had like levels
so you had zero to seven seven to
Fourteen and fourteen to twenty one
[__] tremendous HBO was 18. HBO is 18
and you can press it that's how you did
it you pressed the [__] HBO and you
got all excited nobody was around and
that's the first thing I [__] whacked
it was like oh yeah yeah but I remember
being six in the morning and still
eating those Twinkies
and being jazzed up and not knowing
what's going on in your life like just
being jazzed up and going why do I feel
this way right and being awake the whole
[__] day and years later
one night I'm sitting there I think
talking to somebody and they're like
yeah remember that trip and I'm like
yeah the night before was the most
interesting night of my life because I
stayed up all night eating Twinkies
they're like [__] yeah you did if you
ate the whole box of Twinkies
that'll keep you up all [__] night at
that age yeah getting coked up on
Twinkies
like sucking a dick one after the other
little little brown little brown squeaky
dicks and ever since that time you know
what
if I'm high and I gotta eat a Twinkie
I'll eat it but I don't think I think
since that eighth grade I think I've had
two Twinkies yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was his thing for like a dollar a
piece that was his fetish oh my God I'm
into boys listening to them [__] we got
there he was [__] the [__] out of her
doggy style we all ran away we were like
modified
we got there 10 minutes before he
started [__] it we're like not even
in there and all of a sudden you heard
her oh and he's like yeah that said
sucking
we tried to look
it wasn't the name of us yeah look at
that window we just heard them [__]
[__] and I heard meat like that's the
first time I heard balls yeah and we ran
out of that dog the next day
the next day he's like did you guys come
by
oh my God
that's the weirdest [__] neighborhood
guy I've ever heard
oh my God holy [__]
that guy's great but the Ali Brothers
think about how many like first you had
with that guy
first drinking [__]
son of a drink with him I don't think
even if you no no no no no he got his
weed and he was like dog if I do this
for you you got to keep it on the level
I can't have you know he was very
careful but the Ali brothers were the
first per people that told me like this
all was happening at once so I was
living on giving that Terrace but I
would play on 26th Street and the Ali
brothers were hysterical the Ali
brothers were the first people I ever
met in my life that went through a
hookah house
and they would both describe the
experience to me and it was like a
[__] perfect film you couldn't write
this now my memory because Juan Ali was
very intelligent and he would say yeah
you give him 10 bucks and you go in the
back room and they [__] take your
shoes off and they take a bucket out and
they wash your dick
and they get on the bed and they ask you
what do you want to do if you want a 69
and we do everything
and we do everything we're there for
like and how we eat them they give us a
massage the whole fight when you're
[__] 12
and the 13 year olds telling you this
[__] you're my it's like Pink Floyd the
first time yeah you go home and think
about that [__] and think about the
possibilities like maybe I'll go over
there I'll put on my best suit
I'll get 10 bucks and see what the Bronx
has to offer are you [__] kidding me
but every Monday there'd be a circle
around these two
and they'd be timeless all their sexual
experts you know
the [__] Libras until I hit that
right there right next to where they
lived was a company called duratest
and they made light bulbs
all sizes they made these things but the
best thing for us as kids was when they
made the office the skinny long ones
yeah oh
25 times nothing will happen they just
break and you get white powder on you
okay so we would jump over the dumpster
get like 150 of those things and
everybody would take an armful and we'd
go to war with each other no [__]
we'd hit each other no Cuts never never
misunderstanding and it was me wanna Lee
Martin Perez all these what Dean laprine
all these white dudes from 2016 were all
out there but there was a roof
a flat roof over a garage
next to Juan Ali's house and there was
access to the roof so what happened in
this war five on five everybody's
hitting each other with these [__]
things I run to the roof I'm having my
own private war up in the roof
and somebody throws a rock over they
throw a bulb over right then another
bulb comes over and then a rock comes
over well I take the [__] rock and I
look at the guy and like I don't say
that and I throw the rock up up in the
air right and I just leave it like that
and also you're here
and we look over not the smart Ali but
the [__] one Alberto the one that
used to always say see yeah like he was
the one that he was like Louie he's like
that character Louis that wasn't
intelligent but he was going yeah yeah I
was there he was that guy bro I hit him
in the head with that [__] oh [__] I
clocked him right here it didn't break
but he got a lump immediately like a
hematoma yeah but it was a hematoma that
got that pus went right to it and he had
a little pee hole in it you could see
and he was on the phone
like my friends didn't give a [__] he
got in there with the rock take him into
one light folks
[Laughter]
is the dumb one yeah
while he was down by the time we got to
him he had powder all over from the
light bulbs I mean you can still see the
lump on his head I'll never forget it
till this day I always look him up on
Facebook or Google them I can't get a
hold of them and that's how they spelled
their name Ali
a-l-e who's a human name I live yeah
house the Irishman fresh from New York
four months the summer dead of August
humidity you go home you wash you got
dirt in your hair but you're still in
the greatest City in the [__] world
it's it makes up for it all the all the
[__] people complain about in New York
it's like ah those are details the the
headline is that my soul is alive I'm
creative I'm writing new [__] I'm
bumping up against Asian girls with
open-toed sandals on the subway looking
down pretend I'm checking my phone but
I'm really looking at those nubby little
yellow toes oh with the good good
[__] uh
not self manicures no paint just the
natural color of the toenail makes you
want to go to one of those human
trafficking joints over on Burbank
Boulevard
trying to whack off on the toes you know
what I'm saying
sweetie one on the floor one on the
table let's split those feet up listen
those [__] third world Nations over
there you know I always drive through uh
either Burbank Boulevard or Magnolia
yeah I go to jiu jitsu and I either take
Magnolia or Burbank Boulevard
and I can't tell you how many times I'll
be somewhere and I'll notice a new
massage ball yep and I'm always
this close to walking in what I go to
one but I go there with my wife it's
right over here they really do a [__]
job yeah they got a happy hour to three
yeah oh you think you're in heaven
unreal Plus off they soak your feet yes
yeah they rub from your knees down yeah
put your hips back in place yep they rub
your hands your forearms your neck they
twist your [__] neck then they take
you in the other room and they rub you
down they put hot stones on you for the
small 40. and they give you a [__]
hot cup of tea on top of tea yeah the
[__] that place is tremendous and here's
the other tip I got a punch card if
you're gonna go to one of these places
get there before three o'clock because
they're not they're not changing out the
sheets so you wanna you wanna be the
first oh no guy on those sheets this
place is tremendous they may change the
face rest but they're not changing
change everything yeah yeah I watched
I've been going there somebody's a kid
from jiu jitsu
said go to this place yeah tell me the
truth I'm not going to get a [__] I
go don't make me go to a place then
because that place is next to a little
store I go to yeah and the two sons
always talk to me about sports and
comedy and [__] so that's a massage
parlor during the [__] joint yeah
please don't [__] with me because I'll
be embarrassed if I walk out and they
see me yeah and one day I was in enough
store
and I asked the guy if he heard anything
about that I'm thinking of going over
there just to cover myself and he goes
people love it it's [__] busy yeah
and they had a sign that said happy hour
12 to 3 20 bucks neck
feet and legs or something shoulders or
something
you get Italy you never went over there
with me no I haven't oh you got to buy
him a gift certificate he won't go his
girlfriend won't we did the Zeal when we
had zero I know but you'll do Zeal but I
don't have that Chinese people and you
know I mean they're immigrants you're
the only one who like you you only like
Chinese people I like how I like always
I'll take you over there with me thank
you because if not he won't go he won't
be allowed to go oh you think uh I get I
went to a play my wife gave me a coupon
for a uh
yeah I live down in Venice and right on
Lincoln Boulevard you know it is there's
all kinds of Shacks on Lincoln Boulevard
oh they do have Shacks down there oh
yeah so she gives me this coupon she got
it in the mail you know one of those
value pack envelopes to come stuffy
clean your carpets and you go get a a
[__] uh Whopper with cheese and dry
cleaning it's like all those coupons and
one of them is for this Thai massage
place so it's my it's my birthday and
she sends me over there and uh and I
walk in and this cute little
little tiny Thai girl behind the counter
she leads me back to the room and you
know take off your clothes get under
this towel
so I'm laying face down and I wait you
know a few minutes goes by and then I
hear I hear the door open and uh you
ready I'm ready and then she starts
rubbing but it's like she's [__]
strong like this is not what I expected
from this girl and she's working elbows
and knees [__] you know deep and I
was like wow this is and then uh and
then gets to the ass and starts oiling
it up doing some deep circles like like
round to the point where I'm going like
did I take a dump today where you start
worrying about your hygiene and how it
smells like and then she goes again and
she gets in that crease between my ass
cheek and the leg you know she's got her
finger in there and I and and then and
then there's like a little ball Grace
and I think oh
then she gets the other cheek same thing
rubs it oils it gets in that crease
second ball Grace
now you got my attention
slaps me on the ass you turn over which
is foreplay for a lot of guys in America
those three words you turn over
I turn over
I look up and
[__]
it's a dude with lipstick on
Asian dude long hair lipstick on it's
not the woman from the front desk
and he starts rubbing my thighs in front
of my thighs I swear to Christ why are
you telling me this I know I did like 10
Stars today this thing of mushroom I
swear to Chris and so the dudes rubbing
my thighs and he starts to he starts to
go on the inside and I start to feel a
little little pressure
and then uh
he didn't go for it
and to this day I think
I don't know what happened like I I
can't I can't look you in the eye and
say that no was on the tip of my tongue
at that moment
I think I would have said no it was the
lipstick
let's see
it was the lipstick when you're laying
on your back anybody shows up a lipstick
you let him suck your dick you know what
I'm saying are you kidding me and one
night I went in there like one night I
was pissed on somebody night like spit
on somebody night like they'd be a guy
in the third floor
but I went in there one time and there
was a guy and they were playing like uh
Wheel of Fortune it wasn't called Wheel
of Fortune it's called like spin the
[__]
and the guy would they would tie him up
naked like Jesus but spread his legs on
a wheel on the wheel and if he won the
The Ballot or whatever they would make
him go upside down and somebody would
suck his dick while he was upside down
the winner of the loser I don't know I
don't know what the [__] but I'll never
forget going in there with that on a
loot looking for a grandma blow like me
and my buddies like that was the last
resort to get blow and we went in there
and everybody was around this like you
know Cherry go go go go go and I'm at
the bar like yeah let me give you grab a
blunt he doesn't hold down five minutes
and I'm like what's going on over there
and it's like it's oh you didn't know
because he was gay as [__] this guy his
name was Joe gas she goes you didn't
know it's you know a wheel of cockline
or whatever so I go over this poor
basket is upside down and this [__]
Puerto Rican little Mustang is sucking
that pipe
but oh I figured out I got to know this
for years like this type of [__] you're
not supposed to see that when you ate
but here's the thing I don't here's the
thing I understand about Joey Diaz and
the church what's happening in general
if I had one story that good you would
know I had that story because I would
have told I would have already told it
30 times this is one of many that's what
I'm saying but I thought about it and I
thought about one thing I'll never
forget that he was sucking the guy's
dick and that was behind them and all
these gay guys like go go go go go
happy
and then finally his bankrupt bankrupt
you gotta eat his [__] no I don't
know I don't know the guy's upside down
he's yelling because the blood's in his
head so this guy's stuck in this thing
but I'm gonna forget that something made
me go around look at what the guy what
looked like that was stuck in his dick
and he was sucking it you understand me
all the blood goes to your head I don't
think it gets hard so this guy had both
his cheeks connected like he was like
laughs
and I never forgot like at that time I
don't even think I got my dick sucked
but that's pretty interesting that guy
that guy's sucking for his life like he
was sucking for his [__] life
[Laughter]
I love how you passed out of the set of
blood but you just sit there and watch
this and watch it for about a minute and
then I went back got my grandma Coke and
left and then I said no to nobody it was
nobody's business you know what I'm
saying
who says that type of people who watches
that type of [__] you gotta watch it if
it happens in front of you at least one
time you have to wait for his Coke you
gotta wait for the coke I might as well
watch what's going on what's going on
with the talent you know what I'm saying
maybe I want to jump in I would love to
get my dick sucked if I was upside down
I think I'd get a panic attack thinking
back like if my head is underneath I
don't care how hot she is if she's just
sucking my dick well it's a race between
passing out and coming is that what it
is
yeah I think I think you hear about
these people that uh asphyxiate
themselves while they masturbate and
I've always thought you know I've
masturbated for a lot of years and I'm
good
but could I take it to another level no
but I'm afraid what if I did and and I
and I forgot to let go of my neck or
whatever that's that's not the way you
want it okay so like the guy from Nexus
he goes into a room I think he was in a
closet and he put put his belt around
his neck you put your belt around your
neck and you hold one and pick your
weight up I guess well you just choke
yourself I think you have to tie it off
because you get how David Carradine one
of the Carradine brothers died doing
that
and then Robin Williams is supposedly Am
I Wrong let's go back here so it's like
suicide while you're jerking off okay
you try to choke yourself you know how
when you're getting choked out you get
lightheaded and a little euphoric yeah
so I guess you combine that with
masturbation and it takes to me
masturbation after all these years
is still so [__] good like I don't I
don't picture making it better it's like
it's all in my control it's Joy it's a
release it's a little shame afterwards
but the actual experience of it I still
can't believe after all these years is
nothing that I still enjoy as much as
that one activity
and there's nothing else close
you know when it comes to me I like
banging one out but I'm banging them on
the road yeah like in the shower in the
shower like I love banging one out in
the shower when I can lay down and sit
and I got time I condition my hair I
shave do you lay down in the shower I
love that [__] I hope for years I lay
down in the shower to me it's if when I
get off a plane that's the thing I look
most forward to when I land especially
at a hotel
that's why when I go to these fancy
schmancy old town I don't have a shower
curtain yeah oh yeah no glass anymore we
don't have a tub yeah they pissed me off
I turned the hot water on
I [__] smoke a half a number
sometimes I'll take a little piece of a
Xanax
and I just sit in that water and I
[__] think
I wait till it gets hot nice and steamy
20 minutes in you shave it's like
shaving through butter yeah you know how
long are you in there for all together
sometimes now
sometimes two hours
the [__] room the shower at the uh
gonna get a call from the uh from
Greenpeace about that where's uh where's
uh what's the hotel estate
Southwood shower
is
where the brick ends
yeah
all the way to there yeah
you walk in you open the thing they have
a sink in the shower
and then they have a gun and then they
have a shower and then they have water
that comes out of the walls and they
have a little bench you know how many
times I've gotten up there at four in
the morning
roll the [__] joint smoke that gotten
toasted because I paid a 250 fine there
I don't give a [__] because by the time
it's just a big room I'll pay I'll smoke
a joint in the bathroom I'm sitting
there from four to six thirty
[Applause]
thinking about my life imagine a
neighborly you know because you could
hear that shower going the Next Room
yeah but you but you used to do that
when you were big right you used to
sleep in there I love when I had the
sleep apnea I realized that the only way
I could fall asleep is if I was on an
angle yeah
and uh you know you go to these people's
houses they're rich
and
you would take a shower at somebody
Rich's house 1.8 million two million
dollars after 10 minutes they got no hot
water
you got a waste of a house
yeah you got your house is a waste yeah
I gotta wait another half hour for the
water to get out you got beat I lived in
a building in Hollywood that they have
one of those old tanks do you know I
used to sleep in there
you keep the water running while you
slept because I feel you act asleep when
I had to sleep after that was 400 pounds
so I would go in the tub I'd take a
pillow and I put a garbage bag on it one
of those [__] happy Hefty Hefty Hefty
I would [__] closed off the pillow I
would put it behind me I would put the
hot water in and it would hit like my
stomach and I just [__] sleep there
when I wake up the paint will be peeling
off the wall before we moved there we
had to paint the bathroom I peeled the
primer off the wall sheetrock was coming
off mold the [__] top was just bold
yeah and you can see where it just
dripped with brown mold every time he
would paint it the mold would come right
through when I [__] first got
diagnosed with sleep apnea that's the
only way I could sleep I love showers
yeah I've always loved showers I don't
understand dirty people whatsoever do
you take baths no I don't want to bathe
in the same one of the germs that came
out I want that stuff to flush okay I
want to sit bass baths is something
like drinking for me like in the 70s
when you watch a TV show Greg walked in
here in the 70s I would turn around and
have a bar with a bottle filled with a
brown booze it could be scotch bourbon
whiskey you don't know but you didn't
have the boss to ask I bought two of
them and I just gave it to you Joey Diaz
I gotta tell you man
you're the real deal just just hanging
out with you for 10 minutes before the
show nothing makes me happier you're
just a [__] real guy you don't give a
[__] no there's no I'm talking [__]
about sober October making me laugh
about [__] Ari I just got here doing
bong hits yeah what are you gonna do
it's a beautiful day to be alive and
change degrees outside we got our legs
yep we got our arms we got our house
right uh no Ed
no erectile dysfunction you ever get one
drop on you fall down a flight of stairs
what's that your dick
uh I'm getting to the point now where
you get it there and once you bang out
one then you're done done like done it
used to be where I could shoot one that
would stay half of the tension yeah and
you go back in there for the second stab
and then lasts a little long and
everybody see stars yeah that got cut
out now I got I got a 24 hour shot clock
on mine now it resets 24 hours it's it's
uh and the worst is I'll go to my office
I get an office like this about the same
size just [__] all business and
little couch and uh you know I'll watch
some Japanese hidden camera massage porn
lesbians
and I work one out and then I come home
that night and the wife throws a move on
me after the kids go to bed and I gotta
look her right in the eye and go too
late sweetie it's too late
that one's gone
no I usually don't bang on out in the
daytime late night type of dude really
yeah I don't know why I'm not a daytime
banger
I like late night when I got nothing to
do at night you're bored
you might as well bang one out I go take
a pee and I'll bang without standing up
no [__] yeah I'm old school standing up
you landed all in the water or is it all
over the place yeah no I landed right in
the toilet and then I close it it's a
little sea monkey remember in the 70s
you put that powder in the water and you
closed them sea monkey I got a back
bathroom yeah I'll come in that coil and
I'll put the lid down
I go away I come back two days later I
got like a half a kidnapped it's like a
hand with a fly on it in there it's
telling me to help me help me get the
[__] out of there flush them down the
toilet you gotta heard of [__] horses
I got a back bathroom that gets those
[__] flies yeah
okay what do you mean they're slow they
get big I don't know what happens I open
up the door and I take a [__] and while
I'm taking a [__] you know yeah I love
taking a [__] with the back door open
yeah
when we rented this house and I saw the
layout nobody comes to that bathroom
you have to walk through too many mazes
so it's my bathroom I got a couple
kettlebells on the floor I got some Club
weights and [__] I got two punching bag
two gloves in there I got my bong in
there I got that like wall watch in the
back door my Santeria stuff
and I got this [__] and it's perfect
and I opened the back door and the Sun
comes in at six in the morning after my
first cup of coffee
and as I'm [__] smoking bunk it's
this [__] flying out of my ass when you
cough
what's better than coughing out a bunker
there's nothing better no it comes right
out
for some reason lately as you get older
you get those extended pieces of [__]
well heck the ones that aren't long no
more they they're like six inches but
the middle has like a four inch Gap yeah
like a mushroom right so your ass
stretches out for a minute yeah it's
like [__] you guys are both saying
yes like what are you talking about as
you get older your body changes okay you
young guys so your shit's changed
last Monday and I gotta be honest with
you I'm on it I mean I do not do pain
pills
but I had an Altoid can that people give
me on the road people give me the
different pills I put in my little
Altoids Vicodins hydrocodone and
everything of that do you know what each
one is no not really not really
you know I have an idea but not really
so some nights you know so we had the
last night before soap October we came
in here and we and I had like six
codeine threes and I hate them let me
tell you how much I don't need pain
pills they clogged me up all week oh
yeah that's the problem they distracted
me all week coffee I could feel this
[__] in my stomach yeah I finally said
[__] this the other morning I ran over
to Pete's the Mexican place up there
they got a fruit salad whatever you eat
there at the end they give you a fruit
cup with the Mexican cream on top and
makes you [__] your dick hard just
eating it yeah give you a couple
blueberries raspberries and strawberries
and uh melon the green melon right it's
tremendous I just went up there and said
give me a fruit thing with no cream on
it give me half the cream I ate the
whole [__] thing and Friday night I
was on that Throne like I said they were
coming out in chunks yeah you could hear
it it's like people throwing sheetrock
off yeah
and your [__] is distended three
times I wonder and then it was like 10
minutes of fun yeah like flushing I had
to get up and [__] get the pogo stick
and push it down whatever the [__] you
call that thing loading the cannon yeah
the [__] I got the big extended one
for gorillas yeah the ones that use it
the gorilla cage in the Bronx Zoo I'm
pushing down on this [__] but
for some reason I attract these flies
and they go against the bathroom window
and they kind of get [__] yeah right
so after a few days they just come into
my Lair and I got a little wheat
container a glass container that's empty
weed and then put them in there I take
one of their wings off to [__] them up a
little bit and I put little holes and I
feed them weed I just give them weed and
for three or four days they're just
eating weed they don't know and I just
put more flies in there I got about
eight of them in there right now do you
let them out no no they're in there I'm
like that's it I'm like that dude
manible like the that collected the bugs
and put them up chubby chicks [__]
yeah and then he would drop them off in
the weeds off the 170. what's remember
the put the cream on the skin that dude
the creepy dude jumped the lotion in the
bucket drop the lotion in the Box I
don't remember bugs going in the [__]
in that movie no it was a moth that was
a moth oh God I don't remember that he
would put Marts in their mouths or
something yeah that's how they found
them they found the moth in the mouth
and right they figured out the more God
sent from some other country yeah no I
used to take those Vicodin I gotta I got
shoulder surgery this is probably going
back five years
I got shoulder surgery just from
repeated throwing [__] my entire life
just the right the right shoulder needed
to be rebuilt and they gave me
I had the surgeon write me Vicodin I had
the general practitioner write me
hydrocodone I had uh somebody in
physical therapy write me somebody I I
was feeling every everyone for [__]
nine months these guys kept refilling it
and then I go into people's medicine
cabinets if I came to your house for
dinner I'd excuse myself to go to the
bathroom and I would rifle through your
[__] and I would take your hydrocodone
because there's anybody out there
friends family that have had me over in
the last five years and you think you
got a little hydrocodone left when you
get a backache you're gonna have to
refill that that's gone thank you for
the honesty yeah that's why I don't put
my [__] in the bathroom
I'd go to open houses I got my
medication in the weirdest places yeah
like my blood pressure medications in
the kitchen next to the refrigerator so
I'm reminded to take it yeah and all my
men met them at the little do pills
you know what I'm saying those are
hidden because I don't want Mercy to
find them I know you got to get a safe
man I don't first of all I don't have
them to put up in mind like some people
take them and they put them in their
medicine cabinet yeah I don't have the
anxiety [__] the doctor gives me yeah I
don't put it in there I don't even take
it on the road I watch more of those
anxiety pills like oh you tell me if you
put them in your pocket before you go to
the store more than I take yeah you know
so but it was interesting before the
podcast started we're talking about the
Friars Club oh right what are the
requirements
well
back in the day the requirements were
that you had to be a man
I don't know what the I don't think
there was ever a race restriction
there's a lot of private clubs in New
York that had raised restrictions you
know you had the uh the union club and
the Players Club there was a whole like
Circuit of private clubs they're mostly
in like old beautiful Brownstones like
five-story Brownstones
and the Friars Club was founded as a
club for entertainers it was for
comedians Porsche belt guys that were on
the road uh Broadway actors songwriters
entertainment attorneys agents and they
would they all joined this club and they
would just hang out and they had a uh
the Joey Lewis bar you came in on the
left and it was one of these old-time
New York bars with the [__] red
padded rubber on the edge of the bar and
then some deep black booths in the back
and they serve you the [__] peanuts
that everybody's pissy hands been
rifling through all day but you eat them
anyway and guys just come in there after
work have a couple drinks and then
during the day guys that come in for
lunch the dining room was [__]
beautiful
it was the Frank Sinatra dining room and
you get the Dover soul and they they
take the bones out right at the table
they come over and they fillet it for
you right at the table and you just put
it on your account nobody you don't
bring money to the Friars Club
everything is just they know your number
they throw it down
then you go upstairs and they got a a
card room guys play cards all day
betting all [__] like these yeah
they're working at night they're Comics
so they have their lunch they play cards
and then upstairs they get a steam room
that's the best steam room in the city
and you walk in
you get your little Locker
and then they give you a robe and you
walk into the steam room
guy comes in he's got a towel and then
he's got a washcloth that they they uh
that's got ice cubes on it and he hands
you that the glass of water and then uh
when you get out you walk into the
shower you take a shower big [__] big
shower with the the power nozzle that
blows that [__] it's like a civil rights
riot in the 60s you're getting blasted
against the wall German Shepherds are
barking underneath the stall and then
you come out and this polish guy takes a
towel not making this up and he [__]
Pats you dry your whole body you just
stand there with your arms out this guy
Pats you dry everything but your dick
and then he wraps a towel around your
waist hands you another glass of water
and then you go back and you go sit and
you put the robe on and they got these
uh these lazy boys sitting outside by
the gym big screen TV variety magazine
Hollywood Reporter and you sit down and
you [__] watch a little MSNBC read
for put a towel in your head take a nap
and then you go out to your show that
night
do you have to let the guy draw you off
why wouldn't you I don't know that seems
a great feeling
how long have you been a member of this
for I joined in 93. and one of the
requirements I mean you got to have uh
somebody recommend you and second you
and then they review you and then you
come in and they have a little ceremony
but they swear you in and
reads the rules and all that stuff so I
joined my father was a friar my whole
life I watched I watched the OJ chase at
the Friars Club I watched you know the
86 Mets win the World Series in that
Friars Club they had a they have a TV
viewing room that's fantastic you know
and the waiters are everywhere and
[__] black jackets and bow ties
getting you drinks and uh and then my
what I sponsored this woman Sarah fearon
funny comedic actress kind of quirky
and I uh
I submitted her she got accepted she
goes to the ceremony and she brings her
friend Aaron
and I'm there and I talked to Aaron
she's with a guy but I talked to her for
like 20 minutes and then after the
ceremony I said to Sarah fearon I said
I'm going to marry your friend someday
and uh
three years later
I started dating Aaron took her to the
Friars Club
proposed in the miltonborough room I
proposed to her
she said yes
the rest is history
[Music]
thank you